we've been super lucky I don't know what
we're doing what we're doing to make it
happen but someone's working really well
we're just having fun and just you know
our motto has always been trying be the
hardest working group and don't kind of
let off the throttle at all and just
make music that we're proud of and
hopefully people can relate to it and
they and they seem to that is an
understatement James Barker band was the
most played Canadian artist on country
radio in 2017
[Music]
the band's debut EP game on produced
four top ten singles and the new track
good together was the most added song to
country radio the week it was released
you get a moment to soak it up and
actually enjoy it or is it just kind of
like a whirlwind yeah I'd say we
probably have like three days off since
like last February so we do a pretty
good job of taking in each more wouldn't
it happen
[Music]
how's your family been reacting to the
success it's hard I mean when you're
gone this much and all of our families
I'll probably like what why haven't I
heard from women and so when they do you
just have to like give them like two
weeks worth of updates and I told my dad
I was like dad just get Instagram it's
gonna be ways you're just checking the
gram and that's what we're doing